♪ ♪
>> LOOKING FOR MY MASK, I’M IN
TROUBLE.
>> Harris: WOW.
YOU SEE THE EIGHT COMING UP THE
BACK STAIRS, HE BRINGS A MASK TO
HIM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN APPEARED TO GET
RATTLED FOR ABOUT 30 SECONDS
AFTER LOSING HIS MASK AT AN
OUTDOOR RALLY IN GEORGIA.
THIS DESPITE HIM BEING FULLY
VACCINATED.
HE IS ALSO PLEDGING TO KEEP
WEARING A MASK OUTSIDE EVEN
THOUGH HIS OWN CDC TELLS THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY, ALL OF US
COME UP STAGES HIM THIS WEEK IN
A PRESS CONFERENCE OF HER OWN,
THE CDC DIRECTOR, TO TELL US WE
DON’T HAVE TO WEAR MASKS OUTSIDE
ANY LONGER IF WE HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED.
>> IT’S A SMALL PRECAUTION TO
TAKE THAT HAS A PROFOUND IMPACT.
IT’S A PATRIOTIC RESPONSIBILITY,
FOR GOD SAKE.
>> Harris: IT’S A PATRIOTIC
RESPONSIBILITY TO GO AGAINST
YOUR OWN CDC.
MAYBE THAT IS WHY THE DOCTOR
POPPED UP OUT OF NOWHERE THIS
WEEKEND WENT FOR A UPSTAGED THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Kayleigh: THAT’S RIGHT,
IT’S INCREDIBLE.
HE IS WAGING THE BIGGEST VACCINE
HESITANCY CAMPAIGN IN HISTORY.
HE IS HAVING A PANIC ATTACK ON
STAGE BECAUSE HE CAN’T FIND HIS
MASK, GOING AGAINST HIS OWN CDC
DIRECTOR.
IN THE CLIP HE PLAYED, PREVIOUS
TO THE SOUND BITE HE SAID TO
CRACK MELVIN, I KNOW WE ARE BOTH
VACCINATED, RIGHT NOW WE ARE
SOCIALLY DISTANCED BUT IF WE
WERE TO SOCIALLY DISTANCED WE
WOULD BE WEARING MASKS.
WHAT CLUE DID THAT TELL AMERICA?
EVEN WHEN WE ARE ALL VACCINATED
IN JOE BIDEN’S AMERICA, THE MASK
IS HERE TO STAY FOR NO
SCIENTIFIC REASON.
>> Harris: I DON’T KNOW IF
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
LISTEN TO HIM ON THIS ISSUE IF
HIS WORDS DON’T MATCH HIS
ACTIONS.
BUCK?
>> Buck: FOR BIDEN, THIS IS
NOW THE PSEUDO-RELIGIOUS
SIGNIFICANCE ALMOST OF MASK
WEARING AS BEING A GOOD PERSON.
THIS IS A VIRTUE SIGNALING, IT
IS WHAT PEOPLE WHO LISTEN TO THE
SCIENCE DO ALL ALONG WERE
ACTUALLY, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA, THE RISK OF UNVACCINATED
PEOPLE OUTSIDE WHEN IT COMES TO
TRENDTRANSMISSION IS VERY LOW.
WE HAVE THE LAST TWO TYRANTS OF
THE CDC HAVE FINALLY RATCHETED
IT BACK A LITTLE BIT BUT THE
DEMOCRATIC HYSTERIA IS SUCH THAT
THEY ONLY LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE
THEY LIKE, WHEN THEY LIKE IT.
MAYBE WE CAN GET THEM ONE OF THE
CHAINS YOU PUT YOUR READING
GLASSES ON EXCEPT YEAR MASK.
>> Harris: THEY HAVE THOSE ON
AMAZON.
>> Buck: I’M SURE THEY DO.
>> Harris: THEY HAVE
EVERYTHING ON AMAZON.
EMILY, LOOK, WE DON’T WANT TO
GET TOO HERE BUT DOES HE REALIZE
HE IS TALKING PEOPLE OUT OF
GETTING THE VACCINE?
IS THIS ANTI-TRUMP BEHAVIOR OR
IS THIS SOMETHING ELSE?
BECAUSE FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID THE OPERATION WARP SPEED
DEALS THAT DROP TO THIS ON
THROUGH WITH THE VACCINATION.
IS THIS BIDENS WAY OF PUSHING
AGAINST THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
IF HE INTENDED TO DO THAT SHOULD
HE HAVE GONE AND GOTTEN HIS
VACCINE IN DECEMBER?
>> Tomi: AT A MINIMUM IT IT’S
SENDING A MESSAGE TO THOSE IN
HIS INNER CIRCLE.
I FEEL BAD FOR THE GUYS LOOKING
AROUND HIM, I HAVE BEEN THE GUY
LOOKING FOR MY GLASSES AND THEY
ARE ON MY FACE BUT IT IS REALLY
UNDERCUTTING THE MESSAGE OF THE
VACCINE EFFICACY REALLY IN A
FUNDAMENTAL WAY AND I AM NOT
QUITE SURE WHY NO ONE IN HIS
CIRCLE HAS POINTED OUT WHY HE IS
OUTSIDE AND NOT WEARING A MASK
THAT THAT IS THE LARGEST SYMBOL
SUPPORTING THE VACCINE EFFICACY
HE CAN DO AND AS COMMANDER IN
CHIEF I HOPE HE SEES THAT
DESPITE ALL THE MESSAGES HE HAS
BEEN TOLD BY HIS INNER CIRCLE.
I HOPE THE REST OF HIS PARTY
REALIZES THAT FOR HIMSELF.
>> Harris: IT’S A GREAT POINT.
MAYBE THEY ARE TELLING HIM AND
YOU DON’T WANT ANYONE TO WRESTLE
THE POWER OF THE PULPIT FROM